a recent Pew survey says 9 out of 10
Americans are celebrating Christmas this
morning but only 55 percent of American
adults say they celebrate Christmas as a
religious holiday 51 percent were
planning to go to a religious service on
Christmas Eve or Christmas Day Cardinal
Timothy Dolan leads worshippers at st.
Patrick's Cathedral as Archbishop of New
York cardinal Dolan welcome back to
studio 57 Norah Gayle a blessed
Christmas to you and all of our our
viewers it's a joy to be with you well
it's a joy to have you here and to talk
about what this Christmas is what this
holiday season means I know you you
recently wrote that something is missing
from the world and we need some help
from outside what we do that's one of
the that Nora is what I would call the
message of Advent Advent are those four
weeks of preparation for Christmas we're
done with them now because now it's
Christmas but what that teaches us is
there's a gap in the human heart
there's we're born with a hole in our
heart we're missing something we're
craving something we're yearning for
something now we go through life trying
to fill that gap up that void up with a
lot of stuff that doesn't satisfy for
eternity it'll get us through for a
while but sooner or later it comes
crashing and we're searching again like
me with a good meal you know I think a
double bacon cheeseburger is going to do
it and it will for about a half hour and
then I'm hungry again okay so we are
there at Cardinal with good taste
thank you I yes thank you very much
thank you so we go through life looking
for ways to satisfy this deep hunger the
steep thirst in the human heart and we
know only God can do it only God is the
answer to the question posed by every
human life now Christmas of course says
God knows that and at Christmas Day
he himself said his only begotten son is
our Lord and Savior to fill that hole to
complete that gap but a lot of people
are really very sad
cardinal Dolan because the world seems
so off kilter to so many people got a
terrible year of Men Behaving Badly
there was a big sexual misconduct a lot
of revelations there was we ended the
year with wildfires hurricanes
Rachel pop racial issue racial relations
in the race relations in the proximate
political divisive Ness threats nuclear
war again my god you think we were back
in nineteen fifty wouldn't you yeah so I
understand what you're saying about you
know we must have faith but how do you
hold out hope when you say a lot of us
have holes or the the time seems so
bleak yes there's so many people there's
the basic question thanks for asking at
Gail God gives us the decisive answer
what he says that Christmas is this look
let's be realistic people walk in
darkness from the prophet Isaiah people
walk in darkness but but but light will
prevail you know what's going on in
nature now Nora and Gail what two days
ago three days ago we had the darkest
day of the year the Sun was at the
lowest now the ancient people used to
say oh oh is it going to keep getting
darker if sooner or later the Sun gonna
die is sooner or later light go to be
extinguished and every year they held
their breath at around December 22nd
23rd 24th they saw the Sun begin to
creep back up light conquers darkness ok
now no wonder we would celebrate the
birth of the S Oh n the Son of God at
this very season when the Sun s UN is at
its lowest and begins its creeping back
up to show us that light will conquer
darkness is it any wonder that we the
Jews and Christians celebrate Hanukkah
and Christmas together at this dreary
time of the year when we're wondering if
there's going to be any light left in
the world the feast of lights for the
Jews the Feast of the birth of the Son
of God Christmas for Christians it's
like God saying my dear people I know
what you're going through
alright every year you're wondering if
we can keep at this
but believe me hope will triumph over
despair
faith will triumph over doubt and light
light will trump darkness okay do we
ever need to hear that I would submit to
you Gail and Nora that the question you
just asked very realistic we've been
through a tough
if you and I went back to some of the
interviews that the three of us did in
past Christmases guess what
we'd be saying the same thing really
we'd be saying I actually I actually
wonder about that we always think we're
in the worst Gale we always think oh my
god it can't get worse but yet we always
come through
Cardinal we've never had a president
like this that many people believe
whether you're democrat or republican
that he's sort of tearing the country
apart they can go hot unifying him do
you have any conversations with Donald
Trump
not too many teary otic Lee I have but
wait a minute
I listen I've got my share of criticisms
of the president I do of all of them but
you're talking to an American historian
and we've all got let's let's look back
you're too young for this but let's look
back to the depths of Watergate I mean
you remember what the country went
through then I'm talking on I know you
are you know but I did let it go from
the newsroom you know but I do remember
and she remember the dreariest that it
was so dismal we thought are we going to
be able to serve and darn it we came
through it's like from the beginning of
the human project which is God's
greatest work of art we thought are we
going to survive or we gotta persevere
or is the darkness around us just going
to suffocate us and every year we make
it and what God is saying is trust is
going to trump despair don't give up the
light is going to win goodness is going
to be stronger than evil life is going
to be stronger than death there's
Christmas and I don't know about you but
we need a little Christmas right this
very moment
you didn't think I'd say no we just saw
Pope Francis celebrate a big birthday
with a bunch of Pizza Pizza how is how
is Pope Francis I think he's doing fine
just turned 81 yeah it doesn't seem to
be letting up does he I didn't get your
Christmas present this year is it coming
later it's I left it out in LA okay good
I got you think I got you last year just
a different color I know you did in the
coffee
a good mood thank you so much appreciate
it